introducing the Linda tech shoulder
restoration system an innovative
solution for a pair of rotator cuff
tendon tears providing a total solution
for rotator cuff repair the Linda tech
srs gives surgeons the necessary tools
to perform single row double row or
trans osseous repairs in an intuitive
comprehensive package the Linda tech srs
focuses on tear specific techniques
which allow confident intraoperative
decision-making and management of even
the most demanding tear patterns
combining advanced technologies with
expert techniques the trans osseous
equivalent rotator cuff repair utilizing
the Linn vtec SRS results in a secured
rotator cuff repair that restores the
anatomic footprint for enhanced tendon
to bone contact while maximizing
fixation strength before the
arthroscopic rotator cuff repair can
begin all other glenohumeral pathology
should be assessed and repaired as
necessary in addition subacromial
decompression either with or without
acromioclavicular joint excision should
be completed and the cuff carefully
debrided back to viable tissue
lastly the tuberosity should be prepared
by diluting it of all extraneous soft
tissue and the margins of the rotator
cuff tear should be identified the
rotator cuff tear pattern should be
classified by assessing its medial
lateral and anteroposterior mobility
this procedure will be viewed through
the posterior portal while working
through the lateral portal the lateral
working portal will be maintained with
an eight millimeter drydock cannula and
the smaller anchor portals will be
planned using a spinal needle before the
two millimeter incisions are made to
facilitate the insertion of the medial
row of anchors
if the terrors classified is simple and
thus suitable for a trans osseous
equivalent repair the insertion site for
the to medial row anchors must be
determined with the spinal needle to
prepare for the insertion of the
anterior most anchor a CrossFit
Universal punch is inserted at the
Deadman's angle or 45 degrees to the
bone surface approximately two
millimeters from the articular margin
near the anterior extent of the tear the
CrossFit Universal punch is carefully
advanced to the horizontal laser line
using either hand pressure or gentle
taps with a mallet once a pilot hole has
been created the CrossFit suture anchor
is inserted down to the horizontal laser
line being careful to note the position
of the eyelet as indicated by the
vertical laser lines on the driver shaft
a second pilot holes created by the
CrossFit Universal punch near the
posterior edge of the tear and close to
the articular margin the second CrossFit
suture anchor is then inserted in the
pilot hole using the matched suture
colors from each CrossFit suture anchor
the free ends are passed through the
torn edge of the rotator cuff to create
a horizontal mattress stitch a
horizontal mattress is performed with
paired sutures from both the anterior
and posterior suture anchors a 10 to 15
millimeter bite is preferable to ensure
a broad expanse of tendon for footprint
compression by crossing sutures later on
in the repair the paired sutures for me
charas on ttle mattress are tied but not
cut the remaining suture ends are
preserved by retrieving each pair back
out of its respective anchor portal at
this point the second suture of each
anchor may be removed as it will not be
used for the final construct
before inserting the lateral pop-lock
suture anchors the anterior suture from
each CrossFit suture anchor must be
retrieved out of the lateral working
cannula
for example the anterior most suture of
the anterior CrossFit suture anchor is
coupled with the anterior most suture
from the posterior CrossFit suture
anchor the pair of sutures is then
loaded through the pop lock anchor using
the suture loading tab once the sutures
are loaded into the pop lock a needle
driver can be placed on the sutures to
effectively allow the loaded anchor to
be hung from the cannula thereby freeing
both of the surgeon's hands for the
remaining steps the shoulder is then
externally rotated to facilitate
placement of the anterior most lateral
row anchor external rotation brings the
ideal point for insertion of a 3.5
millimeter pop lock punch directly in
line with the lateral working cannula
the pop lock punch is inserted down to
the horizontal laser line creating the
anterior most pilot hole for the lateral
row of anchors being careful to mimic
the insertion angle of the punch advance
the pop lock anchor into the same hole
when advancing the anchor hold the
handle underneath the black deployment
trigger this is critical to prevent
premature deployment hand pressure or
gentle taps with a mallet can be used to
advance the anchor to the horizontal
laser line do not insert the anchor
beyond the laser line as depth of
insertion is critical to the functioning
of this anchor if the anchor is advanced
too far it should be backed out to the
laser line before proceeding prior to
anchor deployment the sutures are
individually tensioned while maintaining
a counter force on the anchor in the
hole once satisfied with their tension
the pop lock is deployed by releasing
the safety and applying firm and
constant pressure on the deployment
trigger until the characteristic and
audible pop is heard at that point the
insertion handle can simply be removed
the suture tails are then cut using the
katana suture cutter after the suture
tails are cut and removed the second
pair of sutures is retrieved through the
lateral portal and low
into the 3.5 millimeter pop lock the arm
is then internally rotated to optimize
the insertion of the posterior pop lock
suture anchor as with the previous pop
lock suture anchor the 3.5 millimeter
pop lock punch creates the posterior
pilot hole and the anchor is then
inserted to the horizontal laser line
once again
once each suture is satisfactorily
tensioned and the safety is released the
pop lock suture anchor is deployed
finally with the insertion handle
removed the katana suture cutter Clips
the remaining suture tails completing
the rotator cuff repair once completed
view the entire repair from the
posterior portal as well as the lateral
working portal it is also recommended
that the repair be visualized from
inside the joint to confirm that the
medial row securely compresses the
repaired tendon to the bone and that
there hasn't been any inadvertent
intra-articular placement of the anchors
as the peak anchors cannot be visualized
on x-ray the wounds are then closed and
the patient is placed in a shoulder
immobilizer complete with a small
abduction pillow to allow the axilla to
breathe in an effort to prevent an
irritating fungal infection
individualize the post-operative
protocol according to patient factors
and surgeon preferences